what's the perfect day in the life of
John donaher
if we're talking about a basic non-agcc
now you're
uh I'm really grateful that you sit down
with me on a Sunday uh
late at night but it all starts again
for you tomorrow
so
three training sessions a day what uh
what time do you wake up
do you do like a mantra in the morning
uh do you listen to like uh some zen
music uh what do you eat in the morning
what what what's the perfect day look
like
um
when you say if it's a small animal yeah
to the gods
um I I
usually uh
when you say a perfect day what I think
you really mean is an average day
perfectly productive average day yeah
um so let's take Monday morning
for you uh watching this video we're
filming this late on a Sunday night so
um uh after this I'll drive home
um
we just had 80cc it was uh two weeks ago
it was one of the longest uh training
camps it was the longest training camp
I've ever run because of the fact that
we had to go through three different
matches for Gordon Ryan leading up to it
um
so immediately after ADCC I cut the
training down for the competitive
athletes to uh one session per day for
the first week after ADCC to give their
bodies a bit of a break I still have to
teach two classes in addition to that to
recreational classes so my teaching
schedule went down to three classes per
day
after uh one week
of relative break we go back to uh two
competition classes per day plus two
recreational classes plus an MMA class
four uh Gary tonan and his friends
um
the first class
requires me to get up around 6am
to drive I'm still a student driver so
I'm I'm not very good at driving so I
have to spend a little extra time to get
to the destination on time just just for
the record John pulled in a red
Lamborghini with a
um no you're the worst liar I've ever
met
um my day typically starts pretty early
I don't eat in the morning I just get up
and go to work and I teach through the
day
my last class finishes usually around 8
pm
um during that time I
uh coach Jujitsu I try to find time for
uh one Instagram post per day which
usually
describes some basic theme of Jiu-Jitsu
in most cases unless we've just had a
competition in which case I'll talk
about upcoming competitions or what
happens after a competition but most of
them just Express a simple Jiu Jitsu
theme
I try to do a short workout for myself
um
and uh uh then I go home at the end of
the day I always start by asking myself
what do my students need for me tomorrow
based on what I've seen today what do
the recreational students need and what
do the competitive students need this is
always done in the
light of um uh what are the upcoming
competitions
but throughout the day you're doing a
lot of really in-depth classes so how do
you either prepare for them or think
through them as they're happening think
through
the material that you're teaching I can
look at a class I've been doing this a
long time so I can just look at a class
and be like okay these guys need
distance and this and then I make
Reflections at the end of the day then
I'll take care of things that we all do
talk to family occasionally go out on uh
for dinner with friends
um
dates things like that yeah henzo had to
really harass you to drag you out
to hang out and he was very convincing
and food wise I eat once a day once a
day yeah at the end of the day I usually
stop off at a place like a supermarket
like Whole Foods or some equivalent to
that and buy something simple and eat